oh this week our david begno has been
checking in with people whose stories he
shared with you in recent years uh and
he's been asking them a simple but
profound question how are you now
you may remember a cecil jackson of
houston texas he was battling
agoraphobia it's a crippling anxiety
that forced him to avoid public spaces
but jackson was inspired to make a
change after years of living in fear
back in april david followed him as he
visited places and tried new tasks his
illness had prevented him from doing and
now we are seeing just how far he's come
i'm a 35 year old houstonian and i
suffer from agoraphobia i seemingly lead
a normal life as a local store manager
but no one knows that i haven't traveled
beyond a one mile radius from my home in
over 10 years
my childhood was extremely limited due
to my mother suffering with agoraphobia
and my adult years have been no
different since my diagnosis at the age
of 19. you just read that on national
television how does that feel
it feels freeing finish the sentence for
me
for me agoraphobia is
for me agoraphobia is prison you work
across the street from your house i do
you eat across the street i do tell me
some of the things you've missed all of
my sister's graduations my niece's
graduation tons of birthday celebrations
two grandmother's funerals my sister's
wedding she sends me an email right as
she's about to walk down the aisle
the email she said uh
i know that you would be here
i'm sorry i haven't talked about this
cecil found an online lecture from dr
karen cassidy the owner of the
chicago-based anxiety treatment center
this year he emailed her while i have
never met you it became clear that you
understand some of the challenges that
many of us face
i want to reclaim my life dr cassidy
arranged for a houston therapist to
treat cecil with online sessions but he
was not prepared for what we had up our
sleeve
meeting dr cassidy for the first time in
person
you were the bravest man i know right
now
i've been so excited to see you
i'm going to be
your exposure coach today she flew to
houston at our invitation tell her what
you'd like to do i'd like to write an
escalator yeah i'd like to go to the
grocery store part of dr cassidy's
therapy would be to provoke cecil's
anxiety by intentionally
hyperventilating that this is done to
get him used to the sensation of panic
and learn that he can handle it and
teach his body to not respond with panic
attacks so my goal isn't to make this
easy okay it's to
step into the heat okay and to discover
you can take it okay so where's the
first place we're going cecil so the
first place we're going to go is to the
mall we're going to ride an escalator he
was last on an escalator four years ago
so
let's do it he'd rely on exercises to
induce dizziness in order to push
through fantastic you are acing this
what did you feel um the sweaty palms
the dizziness the
um
the sensitivity to light i think i stood
there for like three minutes talking to
her two minutes talking yes then it just
subsided next up was the grocery store
now cecil hadn't been to one of those in
three years until now
he is doing so
it's amazing it's amazing to be here
lines overwhelm him even the smallest
purchase was a big accomplishment yes
yes yes
i think that sometimes when you suffer
you feel like nobody sees you when you
deal with agoraphobia people write you
off and you're often hidden in the
shadows we see you cecil
we see you thank you
that was almost five months ago how are
you now
amazing
what's changed one of the things i
remember distinctly um discussing with
your writing in the letter was about you
know those obligatory trips to the
grocery store or target you know those
simple things and now that's just a part
of my life i'm learning to go towards
fear
and i think that honestly the the
biggest thing for me has been really
accepting the freedom that was always
there um i just didn't know how to
operate in it there's something about
the way you're sitting and holding
yourself that is even more confident
yeah absolutely and when i initially met
with you that my issue was just
agoraphobia
um and that if i only solved that then
that would be the answer to everything
little did i know that opened the door
to self-discovery what else have you
discovered who i am what i like
what my hobbies are the ability to say
no um the freedom and saying in in the
power and being able to finally say yes
to know that feelings aren't facts um to
know that feelings aren't my ultimate
authority
tick-tock through where you've been that
you never would have gone to before you
started on this journey to give a short
list i've been on the freeway i've been
to a preserve i've been to a number of
parks i've been to visit friends that
lifts could go on and on it has been
absolutely amazing and many of these
things are things that just happened
they weren't planned i just woke up and
said today
i'm doing what i want to do today but it
seems to me you found the way to go
inward and find that you have the
answers to unlocking the issues you
needed to unlock anyway you know it's
crazy i always thought that i needed
something that there was something that
was going to come and rescue me whether
that was a person or a thing and i
thought that that would be the magical
thing that did it and i waited for a
long time for that thing to come
and what i discovered in this process is
that the missing part was me
i needed me
and i hadn't connected that link and
when i realized that i understood that
everything that i needed was already
inside of me it had been there all along
is there a struggle or a boundary that
you haven't been able to cross yet
absolutely i want to be clear in that
it's still a process you know there are
still things that i struggle with of
course there's still places that i
haven't gone such as what are you still
struggling with i haven't been on a
plane
there are still places here that i have
yet to go
but i think that for me the difference
now
is that
i'm okay with being afraid and still
doing it i know it took a lot of courage
to sit down and do the interview with us
and to write to me in the first place
and tell me your story you feel like it
was worth it oh absolutely there was
something so
transformative about even that
experience
for a long time i thought that i could
heal from this and then come back out
and say okay look at what i went through
and i never told a soul i understood for
me
that i couldn't heal and hide
simultaneously and it's been absolutely
amazing
my job is usually asking people
sometimes many times
to tell their story
you came to me saying i'm ready to tell
it and that was such a unique experience
even for me to witness i thank you for
that i thank you and with everything in
me i thank you i think that this will be
a i know that this will be a moment
that i will never forget
i know that my life has not been the
same it will never be the same and i'm
excited by the way do you want to get on
a plane absolutely first person i'm
coming to see is you
[Laughter]
oh i see that coming in the future yeah
that's cool i said to him how's your
relationship changed with your family
right he said rather than them calling
me and saying how are you they call and
they say where are you now oh wow
that's huge i know to think he didn't
make his sister's wedding but now can go
into a grocery store or target whatever
the case may be that's a huge leap yeah
so the moment of change for him was that
initial consultation with the
psychologist
it was a moment of change but i want to
be clear tony he has spent the last
seven months in some of the most
intensive therapy i've ever heard of he
has seven different therapists oh wow
three days a week so it may look
wonderfully packaged and he may look
good it's his part-time job just going
to therapy it's
you
still
a
struggle
to point out because people see that and
they think how come i can't do it seems
so easy what i love about stories like
this is while somebody else is going
through their own journey you can pull
things out of it he said feelings aren't
fat i love that too then he also said
you can't heal and hide at the same time
you pulled out my favorite quotes some
heavy stuff right there boom